uh joining us now are our friends our
posters Matt Towery Insider advantage
and Robert kahali Trafalgar they have
been polling every race all right guys
this is uh your final opportunity we're
going to go through especially the
Senate races a lot of these
gubernatorial races let's start in the
great state of Georgia both of you have
Herschel Walker in the lead Robert
kahali what's going to happen tomorrow
I think Herschel is going to uh
come in first and I think he's going to
get barely and avoid a runoff
okay so you think it's a runoff on
December 6th and in that runoff
what's that
oh you think without it you can't avoid
the runoff wow yeah that would be a huge
win for that would be a big night for
Republicans if that happens uh Matt
Towery do you agree
well I have to tell you I am
increasingly convinced that Robert is
going to be the best pollster on this I
think Herschel Walker will make it
across the 50 percent Plus One
requirement in Georgia partially because
African-American men are going to vote
for Walker at even higher level than
they've told us in the polls
and what about and you can't deny Brian
Kemp has run a great campaign for
governor
oh
you know he's lifting all boats in
Georgia he is going to absolutely uh
well you have a big night let's put it
that way over uh Stacy Abrams so yes
Brian Kemp is going to add to Herschel
Walker's likelihood of making it without
a runoff let's go to this great state of
North Carolina and Ted Budd where do you
see that race Matt Towery
oh bud that's easy
okay easy Robert agreement
yes Bud comfortably okay let's go to New
Hampshire uh poll came out today had
General bullduck up by one uh but you
have a governor in in Governor Chris
sununu that is leading anywhere from 12
to 18 points in some polls is that going
to help General bullduck who also had a
good debate I thought in against Maggie
Hassan uh where's that state going uh
Matt Towery
well it's very close you know that they
don't have that early voting they don't
have a lot of noise before the actual
election and he's been rising the entire
time the British betting houses say he's
not going to win I say he has a chance
of winning it's going to be close uh
Robert thinks I think probably that is
probably even going to be closer
what do you think Robert
yeah I think just exactly what you said
he had a great debate he's now got
Governor sununu behind him a lot of that
happened on your show people saw it and
that's a big move and the guy's done a
bunch of town halls and Maggie hasn't
sat in the basement so I think in the
end he pulls that out but just barely
but I'd say Bulldog wins this thing you
know what you look at General Bulldog
he's not a polished politician uh he's
been a general he did 10 tours of Duty
two purple hearts five bronze Stars uh
he's in it to serve the people of the
granite state New Hampshire and he'd be
a great choice I hope he'd I hope I hope
he pulls this out let's go to the state
of Pennsylvania we paid a lot of
attention to this race you have I think
in in John fetterman the most extreme
candidate ever to run for the U.S Senate
it's still relatively close your take
Robert
and I think in the end uh Oz is going to
get the most votes and I think mastriano
outperforms all of his polling and makes
that a little more competitive anybody
gives it credit for but what happens
after Pennsylvania drags out a week is
anybody's guess he gets the most votes
that sounds like code words but I'm not
going there Matt
okay well I alluded a moment ago to the
to the British oddsmakers who tend to be
the very best at figuring out American
politics go figure and they have moved
this race to favor OS winning so is
Larry Sabato who's known to have a
pretty good crystal ball our Poll for
the fox affiliate in Philadelphia had Oz
several points I think Oz will win the
race I think it's going to be tight and
I do agree with Robert he will get the
most votes we'll see what happens and I
had I will argue that that John Federman
if you're in Pennsylvania you can't let
that happen in this country all right
let's look at JD Vance and let's also
look at Ron Johnson any issues there for
either of you
none
okay
none uh all right then let's go to the
State Department of Blake Masters Robert
you had him up by three today
well actually we our brand new poll has
him about one and uh that's the first
poll that we've put out with um Masters
winning what we've what we've seen
happen is what we expected is as once
this libertarian got out hang on one sec
we're going to dip back into the Ohio
rally with Donald Trump uh he's with JD
Vance let's listen hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else